Brianne and Antonia Jenny Georgia is
finally back outside are you for season
two
so excited surreal and like finally yeah
it was yeah it was such a fun journey to
shoot and I think we both are equally
excited to see everyone's reaction
excited and terrified yeah nervous
anxious ready all of the above
so with the success of season one did
you guys feel like an extra pressure
with season two how was that feeling
I think there's always pressure
um to top yourself or to you know what
do we don't do as well you know there's
always that right
um but I mean then when you're in the
middle of it yeah you kind of just
remember that you're there and you love
it and uh I yeah yeah it was it was easy
to now I think now it's like oh crap
like what are people right right
um there's so much to do yeah you really
just have to focus on the work it's
and you know yeah the scenes are intense
and you have to stay go in the moment
which I think is helpful to not get too
far ahead of ourselves at the time and
think too far yeah about the reaction
and try to somewhat just focus on the
journey in the process exactly
definitely like staying the moment just
like this is what I have to do today
yeah
yeah do you guys feel like your life's
changed so much from Jania Georgia
in a wonderful way I I think um more
than anything I just feel so fulfilled
to be able to
um you know run into fans who really
love the show who feel represented by
the show
um who are just very very excited that's
that's to me what has been the most
gratifying thing
um but yeah it has been yeah it's new
I'm not used totally going to the coffee
shop and someone being like Oh my God
to you know do my hair a little more
often when I leave them almost exactly a
little more under eye concealer yeah no
it's it's a privilege to get to be a
part of something that resonates with so
many people I never could have imagined
that it would have this response and
reaction so it's incredible yeah
definitely and season two it's not short
on any of it I really much enjoyed it so
you guys should be really excited to
share it okay so let's talk about your
guys Dynamic Georgia and Jenny's Dynamic
this season because Jenny's mad at her
mom's a murderer there is who wouldn't
be I don't know yeah I don't blame her
yeah
so how how do you in your own words to
describe how that journey is for this
season
uh it's tough It's really really tough
yeah um they yeah they have really
they're kind of at odds they're at
opposite opposite ends and of a rope and
it's a tug of war
um but you know I think that's what
makes the Journey of their relationship
all the more worthwhile is because they
start at such such a place of mistrust
and and anxiety and fear
um but then you really do see it evolve
and you see them eventually become
closer than I think they've ever been
right um but it's it's definitely
Ginny's Afraid of her mom but then she's
not but then she is but then she's not
and then so but they but at the end of
the day they love each other and that's
that's what we get to by the end of it
we pick up right where we left off only
two weeks have passed so we do the first
couple episodes we start a little bit
lower tensions are high stakes are high
yeah but then as the season goes on
um it gets a little bit more like yeah
we slip right back into being Jenny and
Georgia and
I think the this big elephant in the
room the secret that Jenny knows that's
been exposed actually
forces a lot more vulnerability and
honesty between them that at the end of
the day only strengthens their
relationships
yeah so we definitely see like exactly
what you guys are saying how they go the
ups and downs and by the end it seems
like everything's good we're gonna get
the happy ending how shocked were you
when you read that finale script
yeah
um
uh I I mean I think like we I like we
kind of knew of course we knew where we
were where it was going but but still
having it play out seeing it I think
yeah when we actually sat or at least
you know when I sat down and watched of
course when we looked at it we were like
I was just I thought it was so I was I
was mad it's even more heartbreaking to
watch yeah yeah you can it's a worse
Cliffhanger I think than season one ah
but it's also real life nothing in
that's what I appreciate about the show
nothing's wrapped up in a pretty bow
this is reality so yeah Georgia
is has to be held accountable in some
ways
we'll see we'll see you guys hear
anything about season three like I'm
sorry you have to I have to know
something
I think we're just really focusing on
season two right now definitely um
there's so much happens in season two
yeah we gotta get through yeah gotta get
through this we're hopeful but we're
really really vibing with two right now